before we see the types of terms we need
to understand the concept of the power
of variables let's consider two
different terms the first term is 7 X Y
and the 2nd one is 17 X cubed Y squared
observe the first term it has two
variables x and y what is the power of
each of these variables the power of X
is 1 and the power of Y as well is 1 now
look at the powers of variables of the
second term the power of X is 3 and the
power of Y is 2 both these terms have
the same variables x and y but the
powers of each of the variables are
different let's erase this and jump to
the concept of the types of terms there
are two kinds of terms like terms and
unlike terms what is the difference
between them two terms are like if they
have the same variables with the same
powers don't worry we will understand
this with examples when are they unlike
then two terms are unlike if they have
different variables or same variables
with different powers let's zoom out and
understand a couple of examples consider
two terms say seven XY + 15 X why are
these two terms like or unlike remember
to know the type we just have to look at
the variables and not the constants both
these terms have the same variables x
and y but that is not enough to tell us
if they are like or unlike the next
thing we need to compare is the power of
each variable the powers of x are the
same in each term its 1 and yes
the powers of Y in each term is also 1
as both these conditions are satisfied
we can say that they are like terms same
variables and same power
of each variable what about three x
squared Y and three X Y cubed are they
like or unlike both the terms have the
same variables x and y now let's compare
the powers of each of the variables
let's look at the power of X first in
the first term it's 2 and in the second
it's 1 it's not the same even though the
variables are the same because the
powers are not equal these are unlike
terms observe that we do not bother to
check the powers of Y in each case
remember if the powers of one of the
variables is different the terms become
unlike what about 8 X Y Z and 8 XY the
first term has three variables x y and z
and the second term has just x and y it
does not have said both the terms have
different variables hence they are
unlike just remember these two things
and you would have no problem
understanding the types of terms
you